anyone who doesn't know this doesn't
know anything about it is it not written
that I come not to bring a peace but a
sword surely it is I'm saying there are
specific biblical scriptural injunctions
to do evil I'll give you all the
Miracles and you'll still be left
exactly where you are now holding an
empty sack
you know I was an atheist for 10 years
and one of the reasons that I was an
atheist is the very unfortunate timing
that I was a 13 year old boy when
Christopher Hitchens got really really
popular for being an atheist and I
remember at the time there were all
those new atheists The Four Horsemen of
the atheist apocalypse Daniel Dennett
Richard Dawkins Sam Harris and
Christopher Hitchens and those first
three were not all that interesting at
least not to a 13 year old boy but but
Chris Hitchens really was so clever he
seemed so witty he was so drunken and
sweaty and British it just seemed really
really great at the time and I can't
even imagine how many poor souls he has
led away from God and to Eternal
Perdition really sad now I find I go
back and I read a Hitchens essay or I
look at a Hitchens video and it just
doesn't hit the same and so Hitchin
still has some funny bits he has bits
about how women aren't funny and he's
got some great bits on scotch and tea
and things like that but his stuff on
God in retrospect seems like weak sauce
so the producers have picked the creme
de La Creme of Christopher Hitchens
atheist videos I've not seen these
videos or at the very least I haven't
seen them in probably
20 years and we're going to take a look
back decades after this man helped lead
me down the dark Road take it away if
you meet someone in the street who you
yesterday saw executed you can say
either an extraordinary Miracle has
occurred or that you are under a very
grave misapprehension and David hume's
Logic on this I think is quite
irrefutable he says what is more likely
that the laws of nature have been
suspended in your favor and in a way
that you approve all that you've made a
mistake especially if you didn't see it
yourself and you're hearing it from
someone who says that they did after all
Lazarus was raised never said a word
about it the daughter of Jairus was
raised didn't say a thing about what
she'd been through and the gospels tell
us that at the time of the crucifixion
all the graves in Jerusalem open and
their occupants wandered around the
streets to greet so the excuse the
resurrection was something of a banality
at the time not all not all of those
people clearly were divinely conceived
I'll give you all the Miracles and
you'll still be left exactly where you
are now holding an empty sack
Christopher Hitchens is saying well
what's more likely that you the
individual were deceived or that the
laws of nature were suspended but when
we're talking about the resurrection
we're not talking about you individually
being deceived we're talking about 500
eyewitnesses to the Resurrection being
deceived we're talking about all of the
Apostles being deceived the earliest
gospels were written within three or
four Decades of the Resurrection that
would be like me right now writing about
Tupac Shakur and I say actually Tupac
rose from the dead
well if I said that and if that story
was spreading around people would
contradict me if it didn't really happen
you see the New Testament accounts it's
referring to people who would have still
been alive and whose relatives would
have still been alive at the time those
gospel accounts were circulating and you
have four accounts all of which
basically agree with one another and
where they would seem to disagree on
certain details they do so in the way
that newspapers disagree about news
events
in fact the fact that they seem to
disagree about certain details or seem
to approach events from different
Vantage points actually it would be a
mark in their favor because if they were
all exactly completely in lockstep on
vantage point and every single line
you would say oh this was just contrived
the fact that this was all circulated
the fact that we see this in
non-Christian sources the fact that this
event changed the entire world and has
withstood debunking for 2 000 years and
the best that Christopher Hitchens can
offer is some stupid line from David
Hume weak sauce what's the next one I
never said that I attacked bad behavior
that was undertaken were involved on in
the name of as you put it religion I do
insist that this kind of bad behavior is
in nation religion is part of religion
itself it's not an abuse of it or
something undertaking in the name of
it's a direct consequence of the
willingness to believe in the
Supernatural and the willingness to
believe in a supernatural dictatorship
in particular is it not written that I
come not to bring a peace but a soul
surely it is
um is it not written there are those who
don't follow me shall be deposit most
departure be cast into Everlasting far
not a very gentle or Pacific remark is
it not said that if you don't give up
your family if you don't give up Thrift
if you don't give up everyone who loves
you and everything you love to sacrifice
yourself for me you're not worthy these
are strongly coercive and implicitly
authoritarian or even totalitarian
statement oh my goodness gracious I you
know it's funny going back to these now
because I I still see how they appeal to
a 13 year old because Christopher
Hitchens for all of his British
charm he talks like an edgy 13 year old
online I mean this is not this is not
sophisticated stuff at all by the end
he's he's really misparaphrasing the
gospel accounts Christ doesn't tell you
that you have to abandon your family in
order to follow him though you should
Place him and God first in your life and
then everything follows from that and
then he says Christianity is not a
pacifist religion no it's not a pacifist
religion that's true but it's not a not
a call to violence and he says it's a
supernatural dictatorship and this gets
back to something you said in the
previous video too it says can you
imagine how insane it would be that the
laws of nature could be suspended in in
the course of Miracles you say well the
natural has to be based on a foundation
of the supernatural this this is
necessary the fact that we can speak the
fact that we're communicating ideas at
all which I can't touch I can't smell
them I can't see them but nevertheless
they exist the fact that mathematics
exists the fact that loves and dreams
and hopes and desires and any
intelligible thing at all exists shows
you that there is a metaphysical layer
to reality and it's more more
fundamental than the physical layer
really shallow stuff fit fit for a 13
year old next one some of your most
strongly stated arguments are that
violence death destruction uh the
motivation being religion
uh discredit those who would promote a
belief in God however I think there's a
imbalance there in that the nuclear bomb
was created by physicists and is the the
most demonstrable violence perpetrated
on mankind so I I wonder how you respond
to that well physics isn't an ideology
physicist isn't a belief system it's a
it's a science well that I think that
would be subjective I mean you could I
mean any more than uh
the Marie Curie discovering radium makes
her practice morally different I mean
it's not comparing like with lie what
I'm talking about are specific religious
injunctions to do evil to mutilate the
genitalia of children for example to
take the pastor Douglas Wilson
um who uh Dr Craig was just mentioning
with whom I crossed the sword several
times this year recently in Dallas
happened to be mentioning Tim about the
Commandment to exterminate the
amalekites in one of our debates he said
that commandment is still valid
if there were any amalekites it would be
his job to make sure they were all put
to the sword
and some of some of the virgins left
over for slavery purposes better
imagined perhaps than than described I
think this is a very serious problem I'm
not taking refuge in the commonplace
that sometimes people religious people
behave badly that would discredit
religion that would be a very soft
option I'm saying there are specific
biblical scriptural injunctions to do
evil when we talk about human action
we're talking about political action the
decision to create a bomb
the decision to drop that bomb the
decision to talk to somebody about
dropping the button that that would be a
political action that involves Society
but at a higher level what that involves
is applied morality so before you make
that decision you have to know something
about applied morality how do we come to
those decisions and what does our
morality say about those decisions above
applied morality you have morality
broadly more abstract morality above
that you have anthropology what is man
what is the nature of man such that we
can even make these kinds of moral
decisions and come to these moral
conclusions and engage in these
political actions above anthropology of
epistemology how can we know anything at
all know anything about human beings but
know anything about anything how do we
know and then beyond epistemology you
have the question of theology what is
there to know what is reality what is
Christopher Hitchens stops it like the
first Circle as do all of these people
so that's just science okay well what's
behind the science what what are the
premises that go into that they don't
want to acknowledge that
so you know religion is all about
religion is a habit of virtue that
renders to God what he deserves that's
it people have different views on
religion some more correct some less
correct
but to have this childish
atheism coming from Christopher Hitchens
who throws his hands up and says
religion Bad Religion well everybody
engages in some kind of religion right
they just some people just are not
conscious of what they're doing
unfortunately like Hitchens who speaks
very well but who doesn't who doesn't
have very deep things to say people are
raving about genucel skin care Jessica
from Huntsville Alabama says my skin
looks so soft and clear I've seen a
reduced number of fine lines and dark
spots I found a new lifetime product
absolutely love it Jen you sell skin
care uses a one of a kind proprietary
flower base developed by the founder and
pharmacist who is a great guy by the way
it's also comes along with rare
Botanical extracts and Powerful
antioxidants for skin care results that
work guaranteed I said I would not
endorse the product if I could not try
it if I were not impressed by the
product and also fellas I know sometimes
men are a little skeptical of getting
into Cosmetics too much even slightly
more men than women use genuscal and for
good reason geniusell's most popular
package is available to you today for
seventy percent off 7-0 at genucel.com
knowlesyt join millions of happy
customers who've already fallen in love
with the results Plus for a limited time
get genu cells probiotic extract
moisturizer free with every most popular
package go to genucel.com knowlesyt
genucel.com knowlesyt
some people I know who are atheists will
say they wish they could believe it some
people I know who are former Believers
say they wish they could have their old
Faith back they miss it I don't
understand this at all
I think it's a it's it's an excellent
thing that there's no reason to believe
in the Absurd propositions I just
admittedly rather briefly rehearsed to
you
um the main reason for this I think is
that it is a totalitarian belief
it is the wish to be a Slave
it is the desire that they're being
unalterable
unchallengeable tyrannical Authority who
can convict you of thought crime while
you want to sleep
who can can subject you who must indeed
subject you to a total surveillance
Around the Clock every waking and
sleeping minute of your life I say of
your life before you're born and even
worse than where the real fun begins
after your death
a Celestial North Korea
who wants this to be true
who but a slave desires such a ghastly
fate so Hitchin says it's slavery to
serve God is it now
because
I'm more persuaded by what Christ says
in the gospels which is the man who sins
is a slave to sin and anyone who's ever
suffered from an addiction knows this
you you begin using drugs let's say
you're booze or something you begin
indulging in this Vice because you think
it's an expression of your freedom I'm
free no one can tell me what to do man
I'm just going to do what I want to do
but then the more you do it the more you
feel impelled to do it the harder it is
to stop doing it and then you become a
slave this is why Lord Acton points out
that freedom is not the ability to do
whatever we want whenever we want to do
it but freedom is the right to do what
we ought to do it's true God asks you to
submit yourself to him to to conform
your will to his will
but that isn't slavery that's freedom as
Christ says my my yoke is easy and my
burden is light
and what's the alternative the
alternative is a perverted false form of
freedom
a false form of Liberty which is really
license that makes you a slave and a
slave to a much harsher Master than God
who loves you it makes you a slave to
the devil who wants to consume you and
who often does when we when we refuse
God's grace okay
as it was the fate of many many Jewish
people in Europe to have to wonder to
whom they could turn
um in their time of extremity and I'll
tell you the place they didn't which was
the to the churches that had made the
official Concord out with Adolf Hitler
and Benito Mussolini the churches that
had told their parties to vote for him
in the in the reichstag the church that
had told especially the Catholic Church
they're told it's its Bishops to
celebrate Adolf Hitler's birth day every
year from the pulpit which they did till
April 1945. this is so profound
Massachusetts on which the Nazi party
based itself which uh in many cases
violated the Seal of the confessional to
turn over resistors
um and in all cases turned over the
birth records of the parishes of Bavaria
and the rest of Germany so the Nuremberg
Laws could be enforced and everyone with
even a particle of Jewish blood could be
identified set aside for deportation and
persecution anyone who doesn't know this
doesn't know anything about it oh my
goodness it's so so profoundly dishonest
was excommunicated or threatened with
excommunication by the church for taking
part in the final solution Paul Johnson
a Roman Catholic historian estimates
that 40 to 50 percent of the buff and SS
were confessing communicating Roman
Catholics not one of them was ever
threatened with the smallest punishment
for what they did
or were doing
well just amazingly dishonest on the
history of of the church and in the
second world war amazingly dishonest
it's true Pope Pius XII to my knowledge
never excommunicated Hitler Hitler was
not a practicing Catholic he did however
try to kill Hitler
Pius XII worked quite closely actually
with the German resistance against
Hitler he uh would give the Brits tips
he was a go-between between the German
resistance and the Allies he had a spy
trying to kill Hitler Joseph Mueller a
Catholic priest Pope Pius XII personally
saved at least 15 000 Jews worked around
Rome
but elsewhere as well Castel Gandolfo
which is the papal Retreat housed
thousands of Jews during World War II to
protect them from the Nazis the church
used so many means at her disposal to
keep Jews away from the Nazi persecution
Jewish historians estimate some 860 000
Jews were saved by the actions of the
Catholic Church during World War II the
Catholic Church which was a victim of
Hitler and saw herself as a victim of
Hitler
uh the chief Rabbi of Jerusalem thanked
Pius XII for his effort so it's just
this is just a complete Fable coming
from Hitchens or or what he does I guess
this would be the the way that he tries
to be uh not a total liar about this is
he'll say well you know there was some
priest who was really bad or oh there
was some Bishop who was really really
bad okay but look at the actions of the
church all the way up to the head of the
church in the Vicar of Christ 860 000
Jews saved goodness gracious me I mean
at least in the other arguments that
Christopher Hitchens makes they're
extremely shallow but they're they're
trying in some way to Grapple with some
question of morality but there Hitchens
just has to totally ignore history
whether it's through ignorance or
whether it's just through his deep
hatred of God as a parent and hatred of
God I'm not sure exactly what it is so
revisiting these things it makes me
ashamed of myself that I that I fell for
these these arguments the proof of the
pudding is in the tasting on a lot of
these questions as well and so you you
can see that the arguments aren't very
good and you can go back and read
theological sources or philosophical
sources or question you know texts on
ethics and history I guess in the case
of his last video but ultimately the
proof of the pudding is in the tasting
the scripture Chris Hitchens look like a
guy who was flourishing looked like a
guy who was happy who was at peace who
was comfortable in virtue is that the
sort of behavior you would want to model
your life after is that the kind of guy
where you say this guy has figured it
out I don't think so caused 10 years of
confusion for me but glad I got out not
everybody is quite so lucky to escape
from the misery inducing delusions of
atheism okay I'm Michael Knowles we'll
see you next time